we begin with white house correspondent
peter ducey and what the president
and his team are saying good evening
peter good evening trace and what they
are doing we were just out on the south
lawn of the white house for the
president's
return from an out of town trip and he
made the entire
walk outdoors by himself from marine one
to the oval office
wearing a mask that is more than what
the cdc is asking of vaccinated
individuals right now and it just makes
it harder to understand what exactly
the white house wants people to be doing
the press keeps wanting me to talk about
coving true
after all new cdc guidance affects
everyone
so confusion about why vaccinated people
need to wear masks sometimes continues
something has changed and what has
changed is the virus
the cdc hasn't changed and the cdc
hasn't really flip-flopped at all but
their new guidance about masks for the
vaccinated is not one size fits
all for example the president's starting
point today the white house
requires masks indoors but his
destination a mac truck factory in
pennsylvania
doesn't and he got up close and personal
with maskless workers
after a tour and remarks please please
please
you're not vaccinated protect yourself
white house officials confirm there is
talk about requiring federal workers to
get vaccinated
while no decision has been finalized i
will say that the
attestation of vaccination for federal
employees is one
option under strong consideration but
officials dispute that this is a mandate
since workers have a choice between the
shot
and regular testing so ask the station
what we mean by that is confirming
when which means confirming vaccination
status or abiding by stringent covet 19
protocols like mandatory mask wearing
the private sector giant google is now
pushing their return to work date back
six weeks from september to mid-october
as the cdc had hopes private companies
start requiring vaccines if that's one
strategy in our toolbox i'd be all for
it
masks are now required in the house of
representatives the sergeant-at-arms is
authorized and directed to impose a fine
against any member acting in violation
of this policy
but republican leader kevin mccarthy is
critical of that policy and when the
speaker got wind of that
she told reporters he is a quote [ __ ]
and now he's responded
just today i watched her in a private
meeting not wearing a mask
so do as you say but now she does
president biden has tried to explain the
science many times and that may continue
tomorrow
for the first several months of this
administration every big event
was tied to progress big or small and
fighting the pandemic but the pandemic
was
not high on the president's list of
things to talk about today
the day after this first big step
backwards
on the road to normal trace peter
speaking of expanding how does the
federal reserve assess the economy is
recovering
they see the economy strengthening
traits but they also
noticed that there is inflation for a
while to come tied
to rising prices if the progress
continues though
we may soon see the interest rates that
have been near zero since the start of
the pandemic
raised trace indeed peter ducey live for
us at the white house peter thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else